mais ce passionné analogique ayouba
gouem nos valeurs humanistes qui mouille
les patriotes mia frye timide vladimir
poutine vente et son armée le 25 juillet
et pour cause la russie est le deuxième
pays du classement militaires mondiales
gfp alors at il eu raison de se vanter
que vos l'armée russe
aujourd'hui pour mesurer une armée il y
a plusieurs facteurs à prendre en compte
tout d'abord les soldats avec sa
population de près de 145 millions
d'habitants elle compte près d'un
million de soldats actifs ce qui hisse
la russie à la cinquième place du
classement mondial ce qui fait la
particularité de l'armée russe et sa
dévotion à la patrie et ce dès le plus
jeune âge en 2016 n'est laâyoune armes
ya une école créée par vladimir poutine
qui a reçu huit cent trente cinq mille
enfants et adolescents depuis sa
création
d'après le gouvernement russe par
ailleurs un article paru dans le journal
indépendant de moscow times souligne que
l'on pourrait comparer la yuna milliard
us à la dévotion des jeunes durant la
seconde guerre mondiale
quant aux adultes l'influencent de 1917
où l'esprit de partis exigent une
abnégation absolue et l'effacement
devant les intérêts communs est encore
fortement ancrée dans les rangs de
l'armée russe le vt déjà que l'armée est
glorifié à l'intérieur de la route y est
donc l'armée bien sûr et pour centre de
ce culte de la puissance
concernant son matériel la russie est le
quatrième pays aux plus grandes dépenses
militaires
entre 2000 et 2010 9 on constate une
augmentation de 175 % de son budget et
lorsqu'on compare cette dépense
relativement peu élevé à sa puissance
matérielle
comment la russie peut avoir un arsenal
militaire quasiment équivalent à celui
des états unis grâce à l'héritage
militaro industriel de l'urss
effectivement certaines armes sont
encore utilisées par les soldats dont
une partie n'a pas été modernisé depuis
la fin de la guerre froide
ce qui a posé problème en 2008 durant la
guerre des cinq jours où la russie était
intervenue militairement en géorgie
l'armée russe avait montré sa capacité à
mobiliser 20 mille hommes en 48 heures
or cela dit cette intervention avait
montré au même un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements et l'avait mis en
évidence la vétusté d'un certain nombre
de matériels quant à l'arme nucléaire la
russie a de quoi inquiéter l'oncle sam
en effet quand on regarde les
inventaires des pays détenteurs de
l'armé nucléaire
les russes sont les mieux équipées en
2021 avec plus de six mille missiles
nucléaires déployées stocker et en
retrait les etats unis se placent juste
derrière avec 5500 missiles et la france
arrive quatrième avec 290 missiles au
total mais la russie va plus loin en
développant le poséidon une super
torpille nucléaire capable de créer un
raz-de-marée radioactifs vladimir
poutine justifie ce développement contre
les pays occidentaux pour permettre à la
russie de rétorquer en cas de
déploiement de nouveaux systèmes
d'armement américain en europe
maintenant concernant son implication
l'armée russe est plus active que ses
deux concurrents militaire la chine et
les états unis
il urge de records à ce que l'armée
russe était capable de faire hollande et
8 août la guerre en géorgie
les progressions l'effectif remarquable
dernière exemple en date représentative
de la stratégie russe l'annexion de la
crimée en 2014 opposant l'ukraine aux
séparatistes du dombass d'après les
estimations de l'union européenne près
deux cents mille soldats y auraient
participé en juillet 2021 vladimir
poutine publié un essai exposant les
bases historiques de ces revendications
contre l'ukraine 1 essai révélant ses
ambitions impériales d'après le
think-tank américain atlantic council
suite à l'annexion de la crimée l'otan a
unanimement décidé de suspendre sa
coopération avec la russie mais la
russie n'a que deux alliés son armée et
sa flotte disait l'empereur alexandre
iii en regarder cette carte des bases
militaires russes à l'étranger
il semblerait que ce ne soit plus
vraiment d'actualité
ses alliés actuels sont l'arménie la
biélorussie le kazakhstan le
kirghizistan et le tadjikistan
soit les membres de l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective et ancien
pays et englober dans l'urss mais aussi
la syrie ce qui explique l'implication
russe durant la guerre civile sans
oublier la chine
bien qu'il n'y ait pas d'alliance formel
entre la chine et la russie
c'est deux états sont très proches on
sait d'opinion est derrière nous se
trompent le puissance de 8,2 et à
perturbateurs qui de surcroît estiment
que leur heure est venue avec un peu
l'heure a sonné d'éclat de l'occident et
que le monde est en train de changer
[Musique]